Will Smith has been in hot water ever
since the night of the 94th annual
Academy Awards the actor made headlines
around the world both during and after
the events March 27 broadcast because of
his decision to walk onto the Oscar's
main stage and smack Chris Rock in
response to a quip made by the comedian
about Smith's wife Jada Pinkett Smith in
the aftermath of the slap Smith did not
leave the event and actually won his
first Oscar mere minutes later for his
performance in King Richard the
following day the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences opened a
formal review into Smith's Behavior
while Smith himself issued a public
apology to rock calling his actions
quote inexcusable a few days later on
April 1st Smith took the DraStic step of
resigning from the academy and pledged
to accept any further consequences that
the organization might have for him
while the academy accepted his
resignation its president David Rubin
noted the disciplinary proceedings
against the King Richard star were still
being conducted and that the results of
them would be determined when the
Academy's Board of Governors next
convened now several weeks after the
actual Oscars broadcast the headline
dominating story seems to have reached
some kind of conclusion on Friday April
8 the academy announced that it has
decided to ban Smith from the Oscars and
other academy-run events for the next 10
years in a letter to its members the
Academy's leadership announced its
decision and referred to Smith's
Behavior at the awards ceremony as quote
unacceptable and harmful on the same day
that the academy announced its decision
to ban him from the Oscars for the next
10 years Will Smith gave a short but
clear statement about the ruling telling
page six I accept and respect the
Academy's decision following Friday's
All Hands virtual meeting which was held
10 days earlier than planned the
Academy's Board of Governors issued its
decision in a joint statement given by
Academy president David Rubin and CE EO
Don Hudson in the statement Hudson and
Ruben note this action we are taking
today in response to Will Smith's
behavior is a step toward a larger goal
of protecting the safety of our
performers and guests and restoring
trust in the academy the Academy's
leadership also expressed gratitude in
their statement to Chris Rock for
maintaining his quote composure under
extraordinary circumstances and
apologized for the organization's lack
of action on the night of the ceremony
his Oscars ban means that among other
things Smith will not be allowed to
present the award for best actress at
the 2023 Oscars ceremony that honor is
traditionally given at every Oscars
broadcast to the previous year's best
actor winner the shocking penalty also
comes a week after Smith willingly
tendered his resignation from the
academy the opinions surrounding Will
Smith's decision to slap Chris Rock at
the Oscars as well as the Academy's
handling of the situation over the past
few weeks continue to be varied that
remains true in the wake of the
Academy's decision to ban Will Smith
from all of its events for the next
decade well there are undoubtedly some
people who are happy with the Academy's
decision to punish Smith for his
behavior there are also others who have
taken issue with the severity of the
punishment itself for instance on
Twitter one user wrote Will Smith's
10-year Oscar ban seems dramatic while
another tweeted I really feel like
people have been waiting to catch Will
Smith slipping for years and now is
their chance to crush him a decade-long
ban is nuts many other users were also
quick to call out the academy for
deciding to ban Smith but not the
several other previous Oscar winners and
current Academy members who have behaved
notoriously badly in the past all of
this is to say that it looks like the
discussion surrounding this controversy
is going to continue to remain divisive
in the coming weeks months and years
unfortunately that also probably means
that the discussion itself will continue
to overshadow these several historic
wins and achievements that were honored
at the 2020 two Academy Awards notably
while he has been banned from attending
any Academy event for the next 10 years
Smith will still be eligible to be
nominated and win Oscars for any film
performances he gives moving forward
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Oscars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]